Hello, everyone in Milton.  We will begin the
Chesley Morning Brief for happy investment plans on
July 1st, the first day of July
.
Let's find out how the Chinese market closed on the last day of June with Director Wang.   yes
Uh, yesterday, as tech stocks showed strength, the
index rose by 0.5% to 5%
.  The formation book index rose by 1.8%,
and the regular admission mega-face came down to 3 Jeong 3 Jo
.  If you look at the sectors,
we learned about the concept in the communication, IT, and industrial sectors, while we learned about the weakness in the real estate, gold, energy, and
mobility sectors.  Well, driven by this person's
unrealistic expectations and
funds for buying at low prices, the sectors in Guangdong City rebounded
.  Seed Ucha rose by 4%, the
new Yeokseon by 9%, the Jeonbyeon-tongsi
by 2.6%, and Jeonbi-geon by 3.6%
.  Due to global synchronization, the semiconductor
market also showed strength.  Beopbang
Hwacheon has been
rising every day recently.
Yesterday, Beophwacheon rose 2.8%, Paper
Semiconductor 2.6%,
Jeonseung Tech 1%, SMS 5%, and
Hankook Ki 7%.  Stocks related to the second suspension
also rebounded for two consecutive days.
C-Tier is 2% inflammation, ingestion energy, and salt.   The
7% ball increased by 2%, as you wrote plus
2%.  Oh, the
PCB tolerance that was recently adjusted has also gone up
.  Younger brother Cheongmilryeok went up 5%, Heojeon
Center 8%, and Seonru 5%.
Uh, regarding the large-scale PCB reconnaissance,
there is a possibility that it could continue roughly through the second half of this year, next year, and the year after next.
So, PCP maintenance-related stocks
were also strong assets.  Daeju Laser
went up 6%.  Daeju salt is fine.   It
went up 5%.  Chemical Engineering
moved up to 4th place, Sempers.  Human Robot
Kwon Young-soo rebounded yesterday for the first time in a while
.  Oh, let's set the Sama district
to 6.2% and the silver to 2%.
Taboklim was set at 7% and Ubitech at 7%
.
Energy and financial stocks also showed relative sluggishness compared to these defensive stocks
Batterner fell 2.7% and Signalpen
fell 3%.
New bond and 2-year bond yields have
both risen compared to yesterday.
The probability of externalization is also almost inflammation.  1, 4%
was achieved.   hmm.  In
Korea, I would estimate the average trading
volume of the KOSPI and KOSDAQ stock markets to be roughly this amount
.  I have a rough picture in my head. Regarding
China, you give me updates on the transaction volume every day, and
today you mentioned that 3.3 trillion is
not a high level.
[Snorting]
What would be the average?  Ah, the average is only
half this level before the market surges in 2024
.  It amounts to about 1 trillion.  Ah,
then it has risen to a considerably high level
.   yes that's
right.  It keeps getting higher and higher
.  Well, if you say 3,000, and 5 trillion, that is a
very high level.  Since it is high recently,
doing over 3 trillion is a tiring level.   hmm.  hmm.  If you
look at the listed securities companies in Korea,
there are firms where commissions from trading volume make up a significant portion of the company's revenue, and there
are also companies where other sectors are much larger; I assume it is the same in China.   yes
.  yes.  you're right.
Then, in China as well, are the stock prices of
securities firms whose business model is trading volume good?   It's
relatively not good with that.  The reason is
that semiconductor.
Um,
yes, [clears throat] and regarding this
Holsan, the heresy index continues to
maintain a high level of trading volume, but the index hasn't been able to get away
.  If
you look at the index, it has risen 3% compared to Youngso. If this
index were to climb nearly double digits,
Jungwonju could rise at that time, but while the index itself is
n't rising, the trading volume is increasing, and it is
n't showing a multiplier.   hmm.  It
is the day we look at the daily market conditions, and it is
the time of day, but still, regarding China, roughly
what is the ROE of the Shanghai Composite Index (CSI 300)?   I have no idea
.   As for the
ROE index,
well,
originally, in the long term, the
index can rise as much as the ROE.  This is how we
can estimate it.   yes
.  Roughly speaking, it's probably less than 10%
.   hmm.   yes
.  Then, I even entertain derivative thoughts like whether the securities market should wait for China's ROE to
rise
.   yes
.  All right.  The reason I asked is that the
KOSDAQ surged the day before yesterday, showing significant differentiation from the KOSPI.
However, as I looked at the overall market conditions,
many people suggested that since it was not accompanied by trading volume, it would be correct to view it as just a short-term rebound. In
China, the trading volume was [sneer-like], and since I
can now use the Mark of the Demon King, I was
curious about the level involved.  Then, if
Manager Wang checks that we will exceed 3 trillion won going forward,
can we understand that the trading volume in the Chinese market is performing quite well and is quite high?
Yes, that is correct.   I will
establish a baseline and proceed.   Let
's take a look at the trending stocks.
I think you've explained this to me before.  The Stock.   That is
correct. This is the Jukgwangyeon
inverter manufacturing company.  We are
maintaining the number one position in the global market share,
increasing our market share in Southeast Asia to 60%, and
the proportion of overseas sales is nearly 80%.   The
first actual match came to me.  Well, I
agree with the ranking and Q increasing by 73.8% year-on-year, and Q by 32%.   It
increased by 4% to 44%.  The
security level is roughly determined.  The GP
margin is 41.45%,
up 4.2% compared to the same period last year.  The MP
margin was 22.25%.   I was told to make a
donguipo.   yes
.  Sales of
products such as inverters
are rising in line with demand in Europe, Southeast Asia, and other regions.  I
was told to package the profit margin using the exchange rate order.  ES
inverter shipments surged by 100% compared to the same period last month
.  Oh, the battery 100's
performance has dropped by about 20 to 260%
.  The GP margin for the retirement Markage ES
inverter is 52.1%
.  The solar inverter yielded 32.1% and
1%, while the battery GP margin
came out at 32.8% and 8%.
Right now,
all the orbiters are operating at full capacity.
Almost all of the stock has been sold out.
There is also a possibility of price increases and additional capacity expansion.  Prices were raised in the first quarter
.  The price for March
was improved, and the price was additionally raised for May as well
.  So, there is a
possibility that we can expect some improvement in the second quarter
.  The market consortium ranking for the second quarter
is expected to increase by 10% to 20% compared to the previous quarter.  If the second half
turns out well,
there is a possibility that the stock price could jump.
Looking at the report released yesterday, it presented
buying risks due to strong demand, ASP price increases, and capacity scouting
.  It was estimated that the
foreign exchange for the next year and the year after next would be 7.2 billion and
8.2 billion respectively compared to this year, and an
increase of 75%, 27%, and 20% compared to the same period
.   If you do reverse coral,
originally Yesanpia
becomes 24 times.  Next year there is only 19 times, and the year
after that there is only 15 times. With this
improving trend, you can receive about 25 times starting from the 20th
.  So, if we proceed with next year's
funding and apply a 25x PR, there is a
possibility that the TP will be 139.   If you
reduce it by 30% compared to yesterday's price, it might come out
.  I am not very familiar with this sector, but regarding the
company... well, it is a
company that manufactures inverters. Yes, the
upstream industry is residential.
So, if it is residential,
is it general houses or apartments? Yes, I mean
houses and apartments. The
reason you wrote "residential" here is that if you also
consider
factories,
then when we invest in a stock, we
look at things like profitability and the company's market growth potential.
So, is the company's upstream industry the housing
market?  Uh, you can check the housing market
.  Because, especially regarding housing development, this
company has almost all of its assets overseas
.  So, we need to take a
close look at the situation overseas.
Because two or three years ago,
electricity prices skyrocketed in the Yul-up sector.
At that time, I had already set the point of view for the ESG importer, Busan
.   There is a
reason for that.  Because if electricity
prices go up, you can be understood in return
.   hmm.
yes.  And if you pay the full gas price, you
can also get a Banzai.  If there is a shortage of stamina
supply, we will provide the
maximum amount there.
So recently, well,
risks have arisen in the eastern region, and also, the
weather in Europe is hot right now.
So, I saw an article recently saying that the European
region is expanding its air conditioner sales
.   hmm.
So, considering this, there is a possibility that the ES
inverter can be combined to receive IV fluids
.   hmm.
So, we mainly need to look at the stagnation of the European market
.  These days, regarding European markets, there is
constant talk about things like customs taxes by the European government
.  So
recently, I have completely changed my perspective.
However, this company is making the best value-for-money
products.
Hmm.
If this tariff is applied,
we can see the cost per unit of the situation.
So, when purchasing everything, the price might result in some additional damage
.   hmm.  I do
n't think long-term observation is very meaningful, so I believe that for a company like this, the
stock price can rise in tandem with the upward-trending index in practice
.   hmm.  yes
.  When I first heard you say that, I
thought there would be demand for new homes being built. Of course,
there is that demand, but I
suppose there could also be demand for replacements from people living in their existing homes
.
Yes, that is correct. Regarding what you
mentioned below about the inverter GPM based on 2025 standards for solar power, that is simply the
GPM by industry,
not the sales proportion.
Ah, it is not the proportion of sales.  yes.   It is
absolutely suitable for residential use right now
.   It
seems like a focused company.
Uh, since we are dealing with the global housing and construction markets as our
upstream industries, when the
construction market improves and we are
concerned about which company will secure more orders and undertake more construction projects in the future, we will
use Deok-eop stock inverters.
Investing in this company with this mindset might make it a bit
safer.
Hmm, that's right.  yes.
Looking at the valuations, it doesn't seem like a
stock that will break through the band relatively easily, so I will keep it on my
watchlist
.
Let's look at the Chinese market up to this point.  Next, let's
take a look with the cooking show at how the US market wrapped up the last day of June yesterday.   yes
.  Uh, I will now report on the US market yesterday
.  First of all, with AI and semiconductors
driving the market up again, the
US market closed yesterday, February 30,
rising for two consecutive trading days.
As I pointed out again yesterday, it was a market that
wrapped up the first half and the second quarter
.  It is said that SP and Lasdaq
recorded their strongest quarterly performance since 2022.  So,
what are the indicators for 2022?   To
elaborate further,
in the second quarter of 2022, well, there was COVID-19.   Regarding the
policy
rebound,
however, the difference this time is that since AI and
semiconductors are now the core themes, the nature of the earnings expectations is somewhat different in that they are driven by such
investment cycles and economic recovery
.  However, I
think I can say that we have wrapped up the first half of the year, recording our best performance to date.
So, as I plan to continue discussing today, I wanted to
emphasize how the semiconductor sector is driving growth and how important the semiconductor theme will be when looking at the second half of the year. That is why I
presented the first-half performance results in this manner first.  So, please
scroll down and we will start by looking at the major indices
.  First of all, among the major indices, the
DADAO index and the Russell 2000 index recorded new highs
.  In the case of all of them, they
rose by 0.26% and
recorded an all-time high closing price in the 52,000-point range
.  Now, private small-to-medium-sized stock
LeSlie Chen also continued its streak of consecutive new highs, rising for four consecutive trading days
.   I should
also mention the S&P 500 and Nasdaq, which have continued to show strong quarterly performance. Although
these two indices have not yet completely surpassed their mid-June highs, the
S&P 500
rose 0.79% to
approach the 7,500 mark, and the Nasdaq
Composite Index rose 1.52%, marking the
strongest rebound among the major indices.
Also, since yesterday was the last day of the first half,
I have briefly summarized the quarterly performance in the
text below. I would like us to review them together.
Looking at the quarterly figures, the S&P
rose by 9% to 14.9% in the second quarter, while the Nasdaq
rose by 4% to 21.4%.
So, if you look back at the beginning of the year, there
were geopolitical risks in February, and as
these coincided with the burden of interest rates and
oil prices, it was a first half of the year with significant volatility
.  However, as you have
mentioned that tensions between the U.S. and Iran are easing, chips and memory are continuing their rally under the theme of AI, and expectations for solid corporate earnings are continuing, I
think we can anticipate that a strong trend may continue into the second half of the year as these three indicators align.  As I
pointed out before, the center of this rebound
was once again semiconductors.  If
you look at the Philadelphia Semiconductor Index first, it
recently underwent a correction of about 10% from its peak
.  However, as
noted, it surged by about 3.9% yesterday,
recovering a significant portion of the losses.  Looking at it on a quarterly basis, it has
risen by over 80%,
effectively recording the best quarterly performance
.   If
you look at the individual stocks,
SanDisk in the conductor sector rose very strongly yesterday
.  It rose by about 11%,
and equipment testing stocks like KL and
Teradyne also rose strongly, while
CPU stocks went up a bit yesterday
.  AMD rose 7.7%, and although
Marvell had fallen significantly, it rose
7.4%, and On Semiconductor also
rose by about 6.7% to 7%.
And semiconductor equipment was strong, and on the
52-week Shinkoka side,
data center,
network, and infrastructure companies such as Anfeol, Arista, and Cienna rose together,
showing signs of reversing some of the previous declines.
Uh, I mentioned that CPU stocks like AMD and Intel have been receiving
attention
.  There weren't any specific corporate issues yesterday, but
Wells Fargo
released a report raising AMD's price target.
So, I raised AMD's target stock price
from $505 to $615,
and the reason was the
keyword "Agentic AI."  With
expectations of server CPU growth driven by expanding demand, and based on the
logic that as AI spreads to enterprise business automation and cloud infrastructure, not only GPUs but also CPUs, memory, and power management semiconductors will become necessary, it appeared that AI-related
infrastructure stocks were rising in tandem
.  Also, 52-week highs have
appeared very occasionally, and for example, the
An panel rose 5.9% yesterday
.  So, in the
case of this company, I think we can explain it by grouping the data center connector
and network infrastructure together
.  Caterpillar also
made the list for the 52-week moving average. Although it is a somewhat traditional industrial company receiving attention for its data
center, power, and construction infrastructure sectors, it
appeared that buying interest was continuing to spread to AI infrastructure stocks and industrial cyclical private stocks, given that stocks linked to data centers tend to rise together.  So, I think we can interpret yesterday's market as
not just a case of the index being low and reversing, but also a market where
52-week highs spread across equipment, CPUs, data centers, and infrastructure
.
If you look at that text as well, the economic indicators were stronger than expected
.  The number of 9 Dolts for May
has been released.  Now that the
7,594,000 won note is being released, we discussed market expectations
.  Also, the June
Chicago PMI was released at
56.7, falling short of expectations, and
both solid and manufacturing sentiment
came out stronger than anticipated.  So, once again, the
situation was one where risk appetite was somewhat pushed back, placing more weight on corporate profits and the sustainability of the AI ​​investment cycle rather than the U.S. economic slowdown.  However, an
issue worth noting was the bond market
.  The interest rate on 10-year government bonds has
risen quite significantly.  Now,
if you look at the right side of the middle section, the U.S. 10-year
Treasury yield has risen by about 9 basis points to
4.47%.   In
the case of the 2-year bond, it is 4.17%,
and although I did not list it, the
30-year bond has now risen to 4.9%
.  So, U.S. Treasury
yields have risen overall, but
long-term rates, such as the 10-year and 30-year bonds, have
risen even more significantly than individual rates.
So,
rather than any major macroeconomic issue, it appears to be the result of strong economic indicators
and the combined pressure of government bond supply and demand
.  I looked into the bidding and this area, and
recently there were short-term international auctions worth about
$92 billion for 13-week contracts, $79 billion for 26-week contracts, and
$80 billion for 6-week contracts
.
However, in particular, bids for the 13-week and 6-week contracts have
dropped compared to before.
So, it appears that this result also reflects some of the burden of international supply
.  I have
explained this using various numbers, but
to put it simply, while supply was abundant,
bond
demand was weaker than before due to a stronger preference for risk-free investments; as a result, you can
view it as international prices falling and interest rates rising
.   To
briefly touch upon the foreign exchange market starting yesterday, the
dollar
appeared to strengthen slightly.  The yen
continued its weakness, reaching the high 162N range against the dollar, reaching the 160 yen level that I pointed out yesterday, which is the threshold for government intervention.  International oil prices have
fallen again.  WTI at
$70 per barrel has
dropped to around $73.   If you look at the
sectors above, the
Technology ID sector
led the market with a 2.5% increase, while the Industrial sector
led the upward trend with a 1.35% rise.   yes
.  On the other hand, while the weakness in real estate, utilities, and
essential consumer goods placed a burden on
defensive stocks and interest-rate sensitive sectors due to the pressure of rising interest rates, buying
interest continued in infrastructure and cyclical sectors.   I
thought it would be good to briefly touch upon the corporate news, so I have included a summary at the bottom
.  Well, to be honest, there were
n't really any major events that could significantly change the direction of the index; they were
limited.  With the
trend of AI spreading into actual industrial sites becoming apparent, I would like to
briefly mention that
Antropic has unveiled a product called "Sciences," a scientific research-oriented AI workbench
.  Well,
massive amounts of money are being poured into AI infrastructure recently,
so the
point to consider is how the difference between the final investment and the final
demand can ultimately generate profit
.  In that
case, it is worth noting that there is a trend of AI expanding into specialized fields, such as closed science
software, which can be utilized
in R&D areas like scientific research and new drug development
.  So, aside from that, regarding
Big Tech news, the U.S. Supreme Court has decided to hear Apple's
appeal regarding Epic Games. The
key issues
raised in the trial are restrictions on encouraging payments outside the App Store and the surgical system. Therefore,
depending on the outcome, it seems likely that discussions regarding Apple's platform revenue
model and regulations concerning Big Tech could be reignited
.  yes.  And regarding the
latter part, you might be able to mention it briefly,
but as financial companies
like Visa, Stripe, BNI, and Mellon
participate in the stablecoin initiative, a trend of
stablecoins expanding further into payment and financial infrastructure has also
been observed.  So, regarding
corporate issues, the main sources of spending are
gradually being identified, and you can understand it as the U.S. economy
itself moving very robustly toward securing more liquidity
.   yes
.  So, to summarize, yesterday's US market saw the
AI ​​infrastructure rally expand further
.  [Clears throat] So, in the
case of semiconductors, everything from
memory to power semiconductors has
risen together, and employment and manufacturing indicators have
strongly confirmed the resilience of the economic recovery.
However, now that the 10-year yield has
risen to 4.47%, as we
wrap up the first half, it seems that for the second half, it will be important to see how quickly and significantly the AI
[clears throat] expectations translate into actual
sales, profits, and cash
.  That's all. Um,
thank you.
We usually say that the more stocks rising when the index goes up,
the better the quality of the market is; it
seems the range of rising stocks has widened a bit compared to before.  That part seemed good yesterday, and
when you summarized it, you stated that the
SP 500 and Nasdaq
rose by 14.9%, 21.4%, and 4% respectively during the second quarter of this year.
However, if we compare this to the annual gains mentioned above, then the SP
500 and Nasdaq would have both
recorded losses in the first quarter.   yes
.
Looking at the data forecasting the US market for 2026 from early to late this year, since the
2024 year
rose so strongly, usually in such
cases, it rises in the third year as well.
However, while it is true that there is a high probability of it going up, to
put it in English terms, it is very... uh...
bumbling. So I mentioned that it is rising with some volatility. It is
not rising steadily every quarter; three
months is by no means a short period, but it
fell significantly in the first quarter, then made up for it in the second quarter and
rose further.
Looking at this market, it
seems that the first half of the year proved that the market is in its third year of a bull market.
Among the Big Tech stocks, the M7, it seems that, ultimately, there are no stocks that have risen significantly above the SMP 500 other than
Google—or rather, Alphabet
.  So,
aside from M7, I also thought that
the spread of stocks centered on semiconductors and the follow-up stock prices are definitely
different between the first and second years
.  Thanks to Yuryu for
summarizing everything perfectly again today,
I think I was able to organize everything really well.
Let's look at the US market up to this point.  I will move on to virtual assets and
work with the junior officer.   yes
.  I will tell you about the market
.  As you can see from the chart, the
price is very
bad.  Yesterday, it showed a trend of holding around 60,000 units, but I
think you can view yesterday's flow as somewhat proving that the announcement of those five [clears throat] frameworks by Strategy was a short-term issue.   As you
mentioned earlier,
since the 10-year long-term bonds have risen, there will likely be some
short-term pressure, and the
N-currency is
currently weakening significantly.
That is why I think
concerns about the liquidation of NK carry trades are continuously
suppressing the price of Bitcoin right now
.
Since the biggest issue right now is strategy,
Vuitton
prices may continue to be bad until the strategy issue calms down a bit
.  So, I would
say that it would be more reassuring to consider opening up to about $52,000 or $50,000
.  So, if you
look at the long-term Bitcoin chart on the right,
since it is maintaining a level of around $58,000, you can consider that the $50,000 level is
open
.  We are currently at the end, and if you look, we
are in an extreme horror section.
Since it is recording around 15, I
personally think [clears throat] that this figure might improve a bit tomorrow, and if
you look at the Bitcoin spot ETF rankings on the right, there
was an outflow of about 230 on Monday.  Therefore, as the
outflow shows no signs of stopping and continues to occur, funds are
continuously flowing out of ETFs.
So, Strategy needs to
buy a little, but
since there is an issue right now, they are unable to buy
.  In that case, I would say that the
price of Bitcoin is bound to weaken
.
And originally, I
was planning to give you a brief explanation tomorrow, but earlier,
various companies like Visa and Mastercard
announced plans to issue and circulate stablecoins.
So, yesterday, my circle dropped by about 18%
.  Personally, I
think that those who get the upper hand first have an absolute advantage
.  So, while I acknowledge and agree that Circle's
market share is currently much lower than USDT or Tether,
Circle is ultimately the most dominant US-native stablecoin.  And regarding
stablecoins in the US and within the institutional framework, USDC is unconditionally the
most overwhelmingly advantageous.
So, while there
may be some valuation fluctuations in the process of seizing market share—especially in
the short term—I
can say that in the long term, the environment is inevitably one where USDC has the advantage. Furthermore,
since various entities are involved, it is
highly likely that they will have to proceed while adhering to all the rules within the established system
.  However, since Circle is a company that currently only deals with USDC, I would say that
Circle will definitely be more advantageous in the long run
.
If you look at the first part of Sunday, A Strategy made a big announcement yesterday. While I
mentioned it briefly yesterday, he intended to explain it in more detail
.  Uh, it's late, but
I came up with the title: A Choice for Survival: Luna or Pivot?   On
February 29, Streetage made a
somewhat historic decision from the company's perspective
.  Originally, Strategy
had a business structure where the company raised funds to simply buy Bitcoin indefinitely.  Hey, I
think I can briefly explain the structure of Lunaterra to you.  Here, there are
three things listed: UST and Protocol Luna.  Hey,
this is currently pegged for $1 a month no matter what
.  So, if the
UST stablecoin
falls below $1, a structure is formed where you
sell Luna—that is, Luna on the other side—to
buy UST and restore its value
.  So, it was structured in such a way that when this structure was broken, a
dead spy could emerge
.  However, because people did not just
buy and sell directly but bought and sold directly through algorithms, a
situation occurred in 2022 that exploited this structural loophole
.  I think you can look at the flow like this
.  The flow itself might be
hard to understand, but anyway,
to balance the two sides, when the value of one side
dropped, I sold the other to fill the gap.
I think you can interpret it like this.  And 3D
announced a Digital Credit Capital Framework, which you can view as including cash research
preferred stocks STIC and STRC,
MSTR and STC treasury stock
programs, and Bitcoin management
policies and plans
.  There are five.   You
can simply look at them one by one
.
It was the first cash plan.  Strategic has
issued a massive amount of ATMs, so you can
consider that nearly 20% of the market capitalization has been lost and the stock has been diluted.
So, you can consider the cash currently held to be about
2.255 billion
.  If you
look at the right side, the remaining
debt amounts to about 6 billion years
.  So, you can consider that there are still about 6 billion years
remaining as costs that continue to cover interest expenses
.  And they announced a policy stating that the current
reserves amount to about 2.5 billion mobilies, and these
funds can only be used for preferred stock,
preferred stock dividends, and debt interest payments, and that
approval from the directors is required for any other use
.  It is said that it has been decided to maintain at least 12 months of
coverage
.  So,
looking at the coverage chart I showed you recently,
we demonstrated a sharp drop in the coverage curve compared to the 12-month period. You can
view this as a decision to maintain at least the 12-month coverage
.  Therefore, it is said that
approval from two or more separate societies is required to go down below this 12-month amount.
Considering the current dividend and interest costs, it comes out to about 1.8 years, so you
can view this as an announcement that they will unconditionally maintain cash for about 1.8 years.  So, I will announce the
plan to sell Bitcoin later
below, but if we
combine the 1.25 billion in funds raised from that sale with an additional 100 million won, you
can consider that we have stabilized the market by expanding our capital to about 3.8 billion.   If you scroll down and
look, the second point is that
STRC announced its dividend policy
.  Uh, the dividend rate was raised again starting July 1, 2026
.   It
was raised to 12%.  I highlighted that the goal is to trade
in the range of $99 to $100, which is close to the face value, and this is what led me to
think that it might be similar to the Lunar Terror.   They
announced that they would decide on the STIC dividend after reviewing the goal, the Bitcoin price market sentiment, and the financial status of the next generation
.  So, the dividend rate had been raised every time it dropped by 90% with
the goal of unconditionally returning to the $100 par value, reaching
12%. However,
since the market interpreted this as a move to halt dividend rate hikes for that purpose, and because it is seen as a
positive development in terms of shareholder returns, you can
view the slight rise in the prices of MSTR and STIC yesterday as a sign of this
.  The third is the digital
credit securities
repurchase program, which is a
program to repurchase research preferred stock.  You can view this as being very similar to a share buyback; they
announced a plan to repurchase the research preferred shares they themselves pronounced
.  So, they announced that they
plan to repurchase preferred shares on a scale of about one year
.  They
stated that they would reduce the dividend burden by purchasing the preferred shares, as they are trading at a discounted price.  So, they announced that instead of buying with the cash they currently hold in reserves, they would
sell Bitcoin and
buy back the 1 billion dollar amount
.  So, I wrote about Luna, Terra, and
Dead Spy.  As I
mentioned earlier, since a sell of the stable point
occurs, the one on the opposite side is
sold to bring it up.  As a result,
the collateral value completely collapsed, and
the price of Luna—that is, the Luna that was just being sold—also
plummeted. This
went into an infinite loop of separation,
causing the value of both to crash.  The
reason I brought up that Dead SPAR is that the
main policy is to boost the price of STRC to fix it at face value. So,
instead of MSTR, they have proposed a main plan to sell assets like Bitcoin to
fill this gap.
Ultimately,
since the value of MSTR moves in tandem with the value of Bitcoin in a leveraged manner, it is practically a foregone conclusion that if you sell Bitcoin, the
value of MSTR will fall along with it
.  So, I personally came to think this time that buying Bitcoin to buy
those stable research preferred stocks on the opposite side
actually makes the structure of the Dead Spiral more
similar
.  [Clears throat]
So, as I mentioned earlier, you
can see that the strategy dividend coverage has increased slightly as we have secured a lot of cash this time, but in
any case, I think I can
say that there is absolutely no structural change
.
Investors who learned lessons from the Luna Terra incident were left with concerns that the relevant policy might not
contribute to STC's recovery
but rather
lead to a collapse in collateral value and a plunge in preferred shares
.
Fourth is the MSTR share buyback
program.  So, they explained
that they plan to repurchase the MSTR common stock on a scale of about one year, but the
market capitalization has already been wiped out by about 20% this time to secure cash through the issuance
.  So, it
got diluted.  So, if you
think there is some doubt as to whether the company will recover due to those factors, you
can view it as follows: regarding
the recent MS share buyback, they
announced a plan to purchase the shares using funds from the sale of Bitcoin, rather than through equity.   The
fifth is a Bitcoin cashing
program.  So, I explained that I would
sell Bitcoin only for the purposes listed below:
when cash is insufficient, I might
sell on a scale of about 120 to 200 million won;
when it is more advantageous to sell Bitcoin to pay interest and dividends rather than diluting shareholders (ATMs); and thirdly, as I
mentioned earlier, when
funds are needed to purchase research preferred stock or MSTRs, or to
repurchase them. I
explained these three reasons
.  So, in the end, the company explained that the program in question
strengthens digital credit and injects strategic flexibility for the purpose of expanding reserves and paying dividends and interest; however, if you
look at the conclusion, in my view, it
interprets the market somewhat in the opposite way.  And while it
can be interpreted that way in the short term, you can view it as a huge change in the long term
.  So, in
conclusion, as a result of this
decision, Stradigie has effectively transformed into an investment company that
issues various securities based on its corporate assets, such as Bitcoin, and manages the
prices of the products within those securities as well as the
dividends generated from them
.  So, it
seems likely that securities derived from Bitcoin, research preferred stocks, or other products could be released.   You can think of it as having ended up becoming a
Whibot, an investment company that manages the products coming out of those items
.  So, personally, I think they had no choice but to make this decision because the
discount rate on STRC, their primary financing method,
deepened, and other financing methods, such as convertible bonds, became blocked.
In fact, I
say it is a bit late because if they had mentioned that this could happen during a market where
Bitcoin was rising, the
decline would not have deepened to this extent, and STRC
financing methods would not have been blocked.
Personally, I think it is too late.  So, in
the short term, the pair of going long on STRC, the research ship owner, and
shorting MSTR
was such a significant decision that it seemed like a temporary investment opportunity, leading me to think that this was not just a long-short move, but a deliberate investment decision.  Looking at it from a long-term perspective, it seems that a
situation has arisen where the MSTR, which was the only buying demand in 2026, and that demand, along with ETFs, could evaporate, potentially leading to a continued weakness in Bitcoin
.  I believe that because the recent lawsuit against Strategy was
also due to exaggerated claims
regarding STIC, a Bitcoin-based research vessel owner, they
absolutely could not take bold options such as paying out dividends, delaying dividend payments, or changing the dividend format
.  And the last
sentence is quite decisive.  Opinions have emerged that MSC seems to have
almost abandoned the criteria it was looking at to determine eligibility for MSCI listing—specifically whether a company is an investment firm or just a software company holding Bitcoin as a strategic asset
.  The reason for this is that,
unlike typical companies that simply
accumulate Bitcoin strategically, MSI is
currently pursuing a program to
manage the prices of products backed by Bitcoin, control the dividends generated from them,
or repurchase those dividend-paying
products.
Therefore,
MSI announced a standard stating that if a company identifies itself as an investment
firm, it will
not be recognized as a DAT (Debt and Investment Company) and
will be expelled
.  So, weren't those criteria a
somewhat poor choice among the investigations that MCI is currently conducting
?  So, from
the perspective of the MSC's exclusion, one could think that
inclusion in the MSI index was a safer choice
.  On the right, there was a
Blind-like post by a current Strategy employee, so I just simply
brought it over.  It is
a bit difficult to verify whether this is true or not, so please just
take it as a reference
.  So, what the employee
is saying here is that the software business is
just... close to an illusion.
Since there was a comment from a current employee stating that they are just existing and conducting business to avoid being excluded from the MSI index, and are currently just relentlessly working on accumulating Bitcoin, I have
explained a wide range of details. However, what I ultimately want to convey is that the
company has completely transformed into one that issues various securities using Bitcoin as collateral and manages those securities or products.   I
spoke at length to tell you that I think that choice came a bit late.  Anyway, I think I
can say that the probability of it being removed from the MSI index has increased significantly
.
thank you  [Clears throat] Although
quite a bit of time has passed, if I may just
ask one thing I am curious about before moving on, if you are
someone who accurately understands the virtual asset ecosystem, you would have clearly grasped the changes after hearing today's
explanation. However, for
someone like me who is at a beginner level, I
think I need to read this again and check it thoroughly.
So, regarding this, to summarize the key points first: since
strategies need to survive in a virtual asset ecosystem centered on Bitcoin, they
are currently communicating with the market various efforts to change their business models.
Because of this, if you are an investor in the virtual asset market,
investing in companies related to virtual assets, including such strategies, is currently somewhat unstable due to various factors. Therefore, I
suspect that it might be better to either hold onto Bitcoin itself or postpone the timing
.  If you agree, I
will move on.
Oh yes.  you're right.  It's basically the
space industry, and SpaceX is in
a lot of trouble.  I
think it's safe to say it's roughly at this level.
All right.  Please make us study in more detail every morning
.  And I
will continue studying until the promised September and October.  We’ve already gone quite a bit through Part 1. We’ll wrap this up now and
see you in Part 2.  Thank you to everyone who joined us for Part 1.
[Clears throat] We will see you briefly in Part 2
.  thank you
[Music]
เฮ
Hello.  Embark on your investment journey
with investment expert Chesley. Chesley Morning Brief.
Today is July 1st, and it is
Wednesday.  We will now begin
Part 2 of the second half of the major events, the first day of the second half of 2026
.
Last night, the US market ended on a positive
note with all gains, and as I looked around at
overseas markets, I noticed that the
UK market
recorded 4,993 on March 27th during the COVID era, which is quite a lot
now.  Ah, it has
doubled compared to the COVID era.
Since we recorded 1,430, it has
gone up six compared to the current level.
That is correct.
Oh, it is a
tremendous upward trend. Yes, if you look at it, you can see the
tremendous upward trend
.
Yes,
interest rates rose by about 7 basis points yesterday, and there were some
international auctions.  It's
about 81 dollars, but the response rate is
a bit lower compared to before.  So, ah, government bond
purchases were a bit low.  And
among those employment indicators, the
Zolt report that we have been watching has been released, and the results were
better than expected.  As a result, I
think there was some upward pressure on interest rates.
First off, aside from that, the April Case-Shiller
housing prices for 20 cities
have been released, and hmm, they
continue to be a bit slow.
Actually, it rose 1.1% compared to the same period last year
.  The consensus of 0.9% has
been slightly raised.  The power is
0.9%.  Look.
Looking at it by city, it is a bit high;
cities in the East like New York and Boston rose by about 3.8% and 2.1%
.  In the West, the sample size
rose by about 1.3%, and in the
case of LA, it
fell by about 0.5% to 5%. When these were
combined, the total came out to an increase of about 1.1%. The
important point is
that as housing prices and
growth rates remain relatively low,
housing costs are
also being
maintained stably in correlation. Since
housing costs are currently being maintained at around 3% to 3%, I
believe the possibility of housing prices suddenly spike and shock the CPI, given that housing accounts for a significant portion of the CPI, is low.   According to the
Zoltboger, the number of cases
was 7,594,000, compared to 7,585,000 last month.
So, it
came out about 10,000 cases higher than the previous month and about
300,000 cases higher than the consensus
.   If you
look at the ratio of 9 people to 9 job seekers, it
came out to 1.04.  Well, since the number of
9-person cases is a bit high, it
was 1.03 in April.   It
was 03.  March
was 0.95.  It was 95.
So, recently, employment indicators have been confirmed to be positive, both
in the manufacturing and service
PMIs.
Today, employment figures are
coming out with a growth rate of 4.3%. Since this marks the
third consecutive month maintaining a 4.3% rate following April and May, it does
not
seem likely that significant downside risks will emerge in the employment sector.   I
roughly reviewed the macro indicators released yesterday, and now that the
first half of June has passed, I
thought about how June and the first half were overall, what implications can be drawn from it, and what could be referenced for portfolio management
.  There is something fascinating here
. It was really interesting among these numbers, so let's take a look
.
Japan rose 5.6% in June.   Based
on the Mike Index.  And uh,
you mentioned the UK index a little while ago,
but the EuroStars 60, which is called the Pan-European index,
rose 2.5%.
And the Shanghai Composite closed at 0.6%, while the KOSPI
ended flat.  If
you take the decimal point up to five, it
goes up a bit—like 0.3 points or
3 points—and I
confirmed that it rose slightly as of the end of May.  SMP
500 fell by 1.1%.   The
stock market index growth rate showed that the KOSPI rose
by 101.1%, surpassing 100%
.  And Nike is
39.2%.
SP 500 has not yet reached double digits
.  It
went up 9.6%.  Also, considering that the European index recorded
8.4% and 4%, the Shanghai Composite
3.3%, and the SMP 500
recorded an annual average growth rate of around 10%, the fact that it recorded 9.6% and 6% in the first half
is not exactly a bad performance.
Ah, looking at the major indices, the
Philippine index rose by 11% in June
.  With Russell 2,000 rising 3.6% to
6%, generally speaking, the
semiconductor and small-to-medium sectors in the U.S. were
stronger compared to other sectors. The Dow remained relatively solid as it is composed of old-economy stocks, and as interest rates dropped slightly, sectors like healthcare and finance rose.
As I mentioned, the SMP 500
fell by 1.1%, and the Nasdaq
fell by 2.8%; as you will see later, you can
view the decline in the Big Tank sector as having led the Nasdaq's drop.
Looking at the year-to-date figures, the return rate
is 101.1%.
And the Russell is 21.9%, Nasdaq
12.8%,
SM 9.6%, and Bow Index
8.9%.   Haven't you been able to
issue anything interesting up until now
?
That's it?
yes.  yes.  There is
one.   While
looking at this, I realized I need to prepare the
monthly forecast data for today or tomorrow's shoot. I thought, "
Ah, Mr. Choi, I
should use that for the monthly forecast data."
First off, the fact that our country's KOSPI ended at exactly 0% was
a bit interesting,
right?
Then, um, wait a
minute, I'm not sure. Yes, that's right. The
KOSPI's growth rate since the beginning of the year is
101.1%, isn't it?   The
KOSPI growth rate is
101.1%, and oh, the
Philippines is 101.1% too.
Yes, that is correct.
Ah [laughs]
Yeah,
so... ah,
I see.
In the end, Philban and Cospe are
going together.   hmm.
But I
didn't expect it to finish in the first half of the year, even matching the numbers like this.
That's true.  Really?  Ya 101.1.
yes.  And then,
no, I just wish the KOSPI and the Philippine
Index would stay exactly the same for the next 10, 20, or 100 years.
That is what I mean.
Anyway, I think the performance was decent for those who invested in US stocks this year, focusing on semiconductors
.
Uh, if you look at the major U.S. stocks, specifically the
top gainers, if you look at June alone, it
's the AI ​​infrastructure sector. What was a bit
interesting, though, was that while semiconductors are
obviously there, the construction, power
equipment,
Caterpillar, and G-Number Bar sectors
were quite strong.
If you look at the fifth page, Caterpillar has risen 22%
.  G number prices increased by 21%
.  There is a similar trend in AI infrastructure, as well as
utilities and various other sectors.
However, in this industrial sector, with
Caterpillar and the number bar
rising, the industrial sector is
recording the highest growth rate among the 11 sectors in terms of year-to-date growth.   Since then, the
health management of
Johnson Johnson and Eli Mui has
gone up a bit.  So, uh, Johnson Johnson went up
13%,
and ah, that thing went up about 8%
.  In the financial sector, JPMorgan,
Wells Bargo, and Burks also
rose steadily by double digits.  Uh, JP stock
rose a bit, and Banker Minicar was up
10%, so you can consider the financial sector to have performed well, mainly with large-cap stocks. In the
other sectors, the
defense company Raytheon Technology rose about 6%.
Coca-Cola rose by about 3%.   The
major declines were largely led by big tech stocks
.  The so-called M7—
Tesla, NVDIA, Google,
Apple, Meta, Amazon—and although
not part of M7, Broadcom and Microsoft,
especially Microsoft, fell by about 17%
.  And, uh, as oil prices
fell, the momentum of stocks like Exxon Mobil
weakened.  Oracle
rose 35%, and Palantir also
rose about 25%.  Generally speaking, looking at
the stocks that led the decline, the momentum is weakening on the
side that needs to continue spending money
.  On the
other hand, on the
beneficiary side, we can
see that the momentum is continuing, and
intermittently,
depending on the macroeconomic environment,
individual stocks in sectors such as finance and healthcare,
particularly top-performing stocks by market capitalization, have
shown strength.  From my perspective,
there is a macro investment strategy, and since investments were made based on sectors or factors related to the macro, I
think the rise was mainly driven by large-cap stocks.  Earlier, I mentioned that the June Philippine Index
rose 11.1% in June alone and
101.1% year-to-date.
Some subtle changes were detected here as well;
perhaps due to investment-
related news coming out from here and there,
while foundries, CPUs, memory, equipment, and networking are generally rising, looking at the stocks with particularly strong growth rates,
Lam Research
rose by 36.2%.  Applied Materials
rose 60.6%.  And
KL is an inspection equipment, and it has increased by 57%
.  And in the optical networking
sector, Marvel and
Arista Labs also
showed such trends of over 40%.
Besides that, in the foundry sector, TSMC
rose by about 14%, and memory stocks rose by 18.9% and
9% based on Icon Technology
.  In the storage device sector,
SanDisk rose 34%, Wesson & Lisstal 20%,
and among the ETFs, DRAM
increased by 16.9%.  SXX is
12.6% and 6%, so it appears that
SXX is faithfully tracking the general index
.
Among the stocks hitting new highs, there are emerging in the
foundry, CPU, equipment, and
networking sectors that I mentioned earlier, while in the
memory sector,
based on Micron Technology, it has been
somewhat down by about 5% so far.
If we check the valuations, the
general index
is currently trading at 26.5x and 5x based on PR.   The
recent high was about 29 times.   If we
look at it on a one-year basis.
So previously, as stock prices
rose, we
observed the general index undergoing a correction at the peak based on the PR, but now it is 26.5 times followed by
5 times.  hmm.
Even though the stock price is near a new high, the PR is somewhat low.
Crucially, it
is estimated that Micron Technology plays a significant role in lowering the PR of the Philippine Stock Index. As you
can see above, Micron Technology is currently among the
top stocks in the Philippine Index and has
risen to 4th place.   As
you know, NV Dia is in first place.  Second place is
TSM, third is Warlordcom, and fourth is
Micron Technologies.
During last week's earnings announcement, Micron
Technologies' EPS
rose by as much as 32% in just one week.  Therefore, it
can be estimated that Mycon Technology contributed to raising the EPS of the overall index among the top stocks, and consequently, the PER may have decreased somewhat despite the rise in the stock price.  Currently, the PR is 8 points, and
Mycon Technology's PR has
dropped to 8.4 and 4.
So, looking at the overall implications,
semiconductor and
related industrial stocks within the AI ​​infrastructure are maintaining strong momentum
.  However, even within the semiconductor sector,
the strength of the upward momentum
appears somewhat cyclically.
Depending on the news flow at the time, sometimes it is
memory, sometimes equipment,
sometimes foundry, sometimes CPU, and
sometimes networking.
Looking at the stocks that have recently broken through new highs, they are in the
equipment, foundry, CPU, and networking
sectors.
In addition, a rebound was observed in
some sectors such as healthcare and finance, driven by interest rates and macroeconomic stability
.  Those stocks have been relatively neglected due to concerns over the burden of
CAPEX investments by big tech companies, including the M7; however,
as we observed yesterday morning, the
market is recognizing that CAPEX is continuing to accelerate.   According to the
consensus, based on the
four hyperscalers,
Amazon is expected to see a 50%
increase in year-on-year capital expenditures, while
Microsoft,
Meta, and Google, excluding Amazon, are expected to see a 100% increase in capital expenditures compared to the same period last year
.  However, with the next
quarter also showing figures like 110% or 120%, it
appears that for some meta-markets, the free cash flow will go into the negative
.
Uh, we
need to look at the second-quarter cloud revenue of cloud providers because the likelihood of further expansion
increases only if forward demand is strong enough. In the
case of Amazon, cloud revenue is expected to rise by 4%, and
looking at AWS,
revenue is projected to increase by 31.1% this time.
Microsoft is expected to rise by
24.6%, while Google is projected at around 64%. It
appears that Google is significantly pulling ahead in the cloud sector.
So,
the comment from Bitk asking us to check this time is that demand for the upstream is
still strong, and supply is insufficient compared to demand
.  So,
I think it would be best if a comment came out saying that there is no choice but to turn K-Fex into a singer.
Furthermore, if guidance is provided more strongly than the market consensus, momentum
in the AI ​​infrastructure sector
will continue, and as cloud
providers
do not report earnings that are severely degraded, it appears that stock prices will
remain at their current levels
.  Therefore, as long as
cloud demand remains robust and the
trend of sustained CAPEX competition continues, the
AI ​​infrastructure cycle
appears sustainable.  Meanwhile, regarding Big Tech companies, particularly
M7
firms that have to compete with KEPFIX, I believe that depending on the extent of the stock price decline, while a
short-term rebound is possible when concerns arise that the AI ​​infrastructure sector is overheated, it will likely
take some time to recover the stock price momentum in a trend-based manner
.  Furthermore,
depending on interest rate trends and economic indicators,
there appear to be areas where macro-based trading is possible. As you
saw earlier, sectors like finance and healthcare
are sensitive to interest rates, so trading in these areas could be
considered. However, since there appears to
be potential for stock differentiation within these sectors, I
believe it is necessary to approach this from a portfolio perspective.   That's
all.   yes
.  thank you  [Laughs]
But in my case,
when I was creating this monthly forecaster,
organizing this data—yes, the data—was such a hassle.
Ah, right.  But Vice-Chief Choi
announces that valuation every Monday, and
then even though it hasn't been that long since the end of June ended, he
brings up the data again
. When I look at it, it seems like he does a great job of getting things done quickly rather than just looking at it.
Ah, but it
varies a bit from time to time, and you know you might
want to see the data quickly
.  Uh, at that time, the work
seems to come out very quickly.  Sometimes, uh, it’s
a bit less interesting than that, but when
that happens, it
seems to pick up speed.
So, uh, since this June is a period where the
half-year months overlap anyway,
uh,
I wanted to organize the data quickly, so uh, I was really looking forward to it
.  [Laughs] He must be
really holding his own.
Also, as Department Head Lee Yeok wrote down earlier, the
US market has
never once recorded an annual SP of 505 in June in the 75 years since 1950.
Ah,
so now that I think about it, in the US, there have been
many instances of peaks occurring at the end of the year or the beginning of the year. Yes, but in
our market, even just in 2021, the
peak was reached on June 25th at 3,316
.
We have it, but looking at it, it seems like the US did
n't.  hmm.
And well, the course covers things like Contwall strategies and
such, but July is
traditionally a somewhat strong
market.
yes.
But the earnings season starts in July, you know
.
yes.  That is correct.
So, although there was this kind of war in March, if you
look at June and March together, it was after the earnings call ended, right?
yes.   There
was a bit of an adjustment right during the earnings gap, but
if you look at July and August, yes, at the time of earnings announcements
.  That is correct.
Right now, reports like the Zolt report are
coming out, and things like the ISM manufacturing PMI are
coming out positively.
yes.
So, earnings
won't be bad in July, and which sectors or
stocks will go up in July?  Ah,
but I told
Yuri Pro last week during the penalty session that the highest beta is in a bull market
.  That is because, in terms of the
beta concept, the general population has a high beta
.  However, although the SP
500 went down this month and
rose by 11%,
if we look at it, July is expected to be another bull market. The US
market, such as the
Nasdaq and its M7 stocks, has been performing quite well, so I wonder if
they will rebound this time. There are also plans for the
listing of memory chips, and at the
end of July,
Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix will announce their earnings. There are also
continuous announcements about investing thousands of dollars, so that is the situation
.   It seems like the
rally in equipment stocks might
continue a bit longer. Well, yes, I
think what you just mentioned is the key point from an operator's perspective, and that is the
area I focus on and pay the most attention to.  So, for the
rally in the AI, semiconductor, and industrial sectors to continue,
strong momentum needs to
emerge. However, if that sector weakens, the
sectors that have been strong so far could be sidelined as the trend expands, and at that point,
things will really change.
When the color changes, I
plan to respond swiftly.  There are some IBs
making such claims, and in particular,
JP Healthcare
views the investment in Samsung Electronics, SK Hynix, and Daegimo
positively in the short term, but argues that the
momentum itself could
decline in the long term.  Ah, while discussing that, they are
arguing that sector expansion could potentially occur in the US market as well
.  But for that argument to be correct,
well, ultimately, the stance of the
Big Tech companies that are proactively investing in CAPEX
seems to be the key factor.
So, in my view, whether we
fully accept that opinion or
not, we should keep it in mind and
respond only after seriously considering what the reality of those non-tech companies is
.
[Clears throat]
Okay, and uh, I've
often used the phrase that things are slowly but surely climbing up, but it's not like there aren't any bad news
.  Even though there are some bad factors,
yes.  He keeps lifting his head like this and keeps
envying me.
yes.  At that time, I
used the expression that it was steadily climbing up, and I
think it will continue to rise this July, bumping up little by little, because
things like employment came out well yesterday
. Also, the CPI is expected to be released around the 10th of July, right?  yes.  Uh, that is
because the CPI announced in July, instead of May, is the June CPI
.   The
CPI will probably come out well as well.  These
factors are evident in how the
10-year international yield ultimately surged upward to
4.45 last night. This will likely
act as a psychological burden, acting as a barrier to the upside of interest rates just as they are attempting to charge forward.  As a result,
Bitcoin dropped again yesterday
.   Yeah,
yeah.  Since we are seeing it drop to $58,700, and I’m wondering when
I should
buy some stocks in between, as you
mentioned earlier regarding macro placements,
yes, inflation data that could stimulate interest rates will be
released again in July,
and based on that, the FMC
meeting is on July 29th, so
yes.  Since such factors will act as a cooling agent for the market,
rather than following a trend-following strategy and chasing the market until July, a
strategy of making active investments whenever such opportunities arise
remains valid in July.  I'm going to write the monthly outlook like this
.  Actually, when I
looked at the KOSPI forecast from February, you had
written down an 8% range.   It
seems like you predicted a bit of a cross shape and got it exactly right. Of course, it
turned out to be 12% at the bottom and 10% at the top, but
watching that, I really thought it was amazing.
Oh, thank you.  Oh, our
President Choi doesn't usually praise people, right, Yuri? He doesn't
praise people often, does he? He's nice to you when you don't do well
. [Laughs] It feels the best when I hear that praise from President Choi.  Because
there is someone with the strictest standards, you know
.
Oh, Wooseok-gi is the one smiling the most in our company. Let's admit it.
Do you admit it?
Do you acknowledge the pioneer manager? Yes, yes.
[Laughs]
Since you are leading our Chaesli investors with the strictest standards, there are now
many people who want to learn from Vice President Choi.
Oh, is that so?
yes.  But regarding the honey harvesting site, please say a word from the perspective of someone who has actually learned it
.
You know the English expression "exponential"?  Acceleration field.
Exponential.   yes
.  Total starvation exponential growth.   You
can achieve it.   If you
learn, it becomes like this.   yes
.
Yuri Pro definitely did well in social life.
Oh, I knew that would happen.   You need to be
prepared.  Something like that.
I think Seong-gu said something like that, did
n't he? It might
not get easy. [Laughs]
Yes, life might not get easy. For
those who want to learn the ropes under Vice President Choi, your lives could temporarily
become very miserable.  [Laughs] You have to come
prepared for that.
Oh, and I apologize for forgetting to upload the new car
identification seat yesterday
.  My
son flew out yesterday.  Ah, I had
set the alarm for the afternoon—the new car
analysis alarm—thinking I should record the new car analysis, but then I had a
consultation,
and then at 5:30 or 6:00, my
son arrived at Incheon Airport. Then I took a
limousine to get there, and
[clears throat] on the way back, I was
looking at photos of us coming together on the subway. I was so preoccupied with the
thought of meeting my son there that I can't imagine how
anxious I was.  Really
yes.  My son just returned home, and as soon as he
met his parents right at their house, I ended up
playing soccer [laughs].
Yesterday evening
at the Songpa Women's Soccer Field, I was playing to my heart's content at 8 PM, but then I checked my text
at 9 PM and
saw a message asking, "Mr. Jeon, when are you going to upload the new car analysis?"   Yeah,
yeah.  Ah, seeing that, I wonder
why I can't get this worked up?   I
need to handle things meticulously, like our Vice-Minister Choi, but since I
couldn't upload the analysis for the scholar, I was originally going to
upload the speech item this week, but I plan to upload it by Friday this week
.  [Laughs] Well, I've
looked all the way to the US market.  Next, let's
move on to the domestic market
.   yes
.  I will now report on yesterday's market.   The
Speed ​​Index closed with a gain in the 1% range
.  The KOSDAQ closed down 0.5% to 5%
.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors showed
buying pressure of about 800 million won, while foreign selling remains
somewhat strong.  There
was a sale of 380 billion won.  There was some additional buying from institutions, with nearly
3 trillion
won flowing in.
In futures, there was a sell order of about 8,000 from foreign investors
.
Looking at trading trends by investor type, foreign
investors were seen buying about 400 million won worth of Samsung Electro-Mechanics yesterday
.  Other than that,
buying interest was generally strong in IT and small-to-medium-sized enterprise (SME) stocks.  I bought EOTech, Wonik
IPS, ISC, Renova, Melzoo
Innotek, etc.  In the selling, approximately
1.5 trillion won worth of SK Hynix and approximately
870 billion won worth of Samsung Electronics
were sold.
Looking at Monday and Tuesday, I
saw almost 3 trillion each day.  Yesterday, the scale of selling
itself appeared to have decreased somewhat.
Other than that, I sold Hyundai Heavy Industries and LG Ensol through SDI, and
for institutional buying, I purchased Samsung Electronics, SK Hynix,
Square, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, Isu Petasis, etc.  For
the sale, I sold Eotech,
Wonni, IPS, HPSP, Reno,
etc.  It appears that
while institutions sold off some materials, parts, and equipment stocks, foreign investors
absorbed the volume
.  There were 14 stocks that hit 52-week highs, with
K-Citec, Kumho E&C, and Mirae Industry on the KOSPI
.  On the KOSDAQ,
PSK, Simtek, Tess, VM,
Gigas, InBody, etc.,
were at new highs.
As expected, it seems there were about six material and component stocks on the KOSDAQ
.   The number of
stocks hitting 52-week highs is also gradually
increasing again.   yes
.   You
mentioned foreign selling; I heard that foreigners
sold 148 trillion—or rather, 150 trillion—in the first half of the year.
Selling 150 trillion won in just six months is a first in history
.  yes.  I think this is the first time. Back in the day,
before the financial crisis of 2005, 6, 7, and 2008, they sold 70 trillion during 2005
.  We sold 70 trillion won, but
this time, we sold 150 trillion won in the first half alone,
and that is because
the market
went up 101%
.  And while the selling pressure was
somewhat concentrated on Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix, the
KOSPI 200 actually rose
126%.
Hmm,
exactly a month ago, Manager Oh was
talking about BMP and Parabar, saying, "I'll
buy Parabar for you." I think that
gave them some courage. It's like, "Yeah, let's invest
like Manager Oh." The Donghwa Group
executives were like, "Go ahead,
sell, we'll buy."
But now, starting in July, the National Pension Service is reportedly going to
rebalance again.   yes
.
So you don't have to worry too much,
despite the 150 trillion won in foreign buying volume, right?  All the right threads go up.
That is correct.  Right.  But
rather than selling because it's bad, it has risen too much, so I think it could be considered a kind of
trimming
.
So, fundamentally, you
should only worry about it when the fundamentals deteriorate.
Mechanically
reducing weighting simply because it is high might cause temporary shocks to
supply and demand or psychology, but it
seems the market has very strong resilience and recovers quickly.
Now, let's take a look at the trends of the major stocks
.   yes
.  Looking at the semiconductor retail sector first,
Samsung Electronics' stock price
performance in the retail sector was good yesterday.  It closed up 3.4%
.  On the other hand, Hynix
showed a slightly differentiated trend, rising by about 0.8% to 8%.  The materials, parts, and equipment stocks below were all on
their own;
the stocks that had risen a lot rose a lot, and the stocks that had fallen
fell.  EOTech rose 4%, and
Jusung saw a strong rebound for the first time in a while.   It
surged 14%.  Simtek also
showed a strong upward trend, surging by about 20%
.  And with Daeduck Electronics also
rising by about 16%, it seems the trend in the PCB sector
was quite good.   In the
IT sector below, the
rebound was quite strong yesterday, with Samsung Electric rising about 7%
.  There was also an announcement regarding a contract award.
There was a public announcement regarding an MLCC contract worth 400 million won.  In addition, LG Innotek rose 7%, indicating that the
substrate sector performed quite
well there as well; the platform sector
showed signs of decline again yesterday after showing some activity the day before yesterday, and the Nikkei index
closed up 0.8% to 8%.   There
was a bit of a rebound in the semiconductor sector.   With
Tokyo Electron rising 3%, Murata 6%, and
DISCO 2%, MLCC companies performed quite well in the Japanese stock market as well
.
If you look at the automotive sector, it was a
sluggish day for Hyundai and Kia, while the consumer sector
saw a strong rebound the day before yesterday.
Except for Hamari Search, it
appeared to be weakening again.  The trend was
generally sluggish in substitute cosmetics and OEM instruments for Pion.  Pharma
alone closed with a gain in the 4% range
.
Uh, and if you look below, the food sector is
still showing a somewhat sluggish trend
.  Samyang fell 3.5%.   The
department store chain wasn't
doing well the day before yesterday.  Yesterday, Shinsegae
seemed to succeed in rebounding somewhat, and
if you look at the shipbuilding and steel sectors and other areas,
shipbuilding stocks were quite strong yesterday.  One closed down
about 5.25%
.
Today, the steel and chemical sector showed a strong rebound in the Monday market but
appeared to be turning weak again, and
in the defense sector, Hana, Yeoro, X1, and Rotem
were generally all weak.
And the biotech sector also
showed signs of a strong rebound before immediately turning bearish.
If you look at the securities or banking sectors,
KB Financial Group performed well yesterday, and Kiwoom
Securities also showed an upward trend.  The entertainment sector seemed to be
wrapping up poorly.
The change phase was quite good, with Hyundai, Hyosung Heavy
Industries, and LS Electric showing an upward trend
.  It certainly seems that when the variable rate
breaks below 30, strong buying pressure
comes in.   hmm.
[Clears throat] Please tell me
every 30 times I wake up
.
Oh, I understand.   We are
continuously receiving the volume for major domestic regular admissions.
Okay, next, let's take a look at the data from Researcher Lee Yeon-taek
.  This is about the
cause of the previous top-down stock price correction and the
semiconductor industry since early July.   yes
.  It was about the semiconductor sector, and you
shared some insights regarding supply and demand.  It is reported that the semiconductor
industry is still recording the second-highest increase in industry earnings for June
.
Stock prices have been
fluctuating significantly since likely late June, but it is difficult to explain the recent decline in memory semiconductor
stock prices with a single factor
.  Therefore,
in this article, I intend to
select only the significant factors among the various causes of the market decline and examine
where memory semiconductor stock prices currently stand
.  The first factor is supply and demand.
There are reports of semi-annual rebalancing or the inclusion of SPAC X NASDAQ PACs.  Well,
regarding the supply and demand causes cited for the semiconductor downturn, there
are about two main points. To start with
Banggili valve balancing, it
refers to the process where pension funds, funds, and ETFs readjust their asset weightings to target weightings at the end of a period or quarter.  Simply put, it is said that
if stocks rise significantly, the weight of stocks is
reduced and the weight of other assets, such as bonds, is
increased; similarly,
if a specific sector within the stock market has risen too much,
the weight of that sector is reduced.
Furthermore, if the weighting of Asian stocks
exceeds the initial target, a phenomenon occurs where a portion is reduced to
return to the original asset allocation ratio.
In other words, it is said that semi-annual rebalancing can be viewed not as
selling due to a worsening market outlook, but as a
mechanical selling strategy that reduces excess holdings to return to the predetermined weighting
.  Next is
SpaceX's inclusion in the NASDAQ 100
.  It is reported that SpaceX is
scheduled to be included in the Nasdaq 100 on July 7
.  SpaceX can be considered a mega-enterprise ranking in the
top 6 of U.S. stocks in terms of market capitalization
.  Therefore, it is said that there is clearly a possibility that some of the
existing NASDAQ constituent stocks will have to be sold during the SpaceX profit-making process
.  However, it is said that just because SpaceX is
included in the Nasdaq 100, its
market capitalization of approximately $2 trillion is
not reflected in the index exactly as it is
.  It is said that the actual weighting varies significantly depending on the ratio of free float shares
and the free float weighting,
and
MonixStar estimates the actual weight of the Spex X in the
NASDAQ 100 to be around 1.8 to
1.26
.  Therefore, I mentioned that while there may be
short-term supply and demand pressure on semiconductor stocks after the inclusion, the
impact could be relatively limited
.   There
are other factors.  I mentioned concerns regarding AI investment, as
well as various factors such as expansion, lawsuits, and short-term overheating.
First, I plan to analyze the concerns regarding AI investment
separately in the next post.
However, if you ask whether AI investment is starting to decline
now, my
opinion is that it is not quite the case yet.  Regarding litigation issues, a
class action lawsuit filed in a California court concerning DRAM price fixing has recently
become a hot topic, but based solely on the details disclosed so far, it is
difficult to view this as a problem significant enough to shake the memory semiconductor industry.  And they
say that in antitrust lawsuits, the key is not the fact that prices skyrocketed, but concrete evidence that collusion occurred.  I believe that the burden of short-term overheating is one of the key factors for the correction, and it is said that
during this rally, whenever the stock price fell below the 30-day moving
average, it was perceived as a bottom
.
So, it can be seen as a process of resolving the remaining gap burden
.  I mentioned that some view the recent decline as a normalization of weighting for the
biggest winners of the first half, rather than a deterioration of fundamentals
.  I mentioned that, in
terms of supply and demand, there is a possibility that the
burden will be alleviated during rebalancing after the end-of-month trading, and in
terms of divergence, it appears that the
burden of short-term overheating may ease around early July
.
If you look at the cards on the right first, you
can see that the gap between Samsung Electronics and SK NIX is 30
.  There is still a gap, but we are
talking about early June compared to early this month.  It is said that the situation has eased significantly compared to early June, and the
gap between the two has narrowed a bit faster
.  It is said that
there was a stock price correction when the 30-day gap widened significantly
.  Certainly, Samsung Electronics'
stock price has weakened significantly compared to SK Hynix recently, and
since it rose less even when it did, it has dropped to almost the 30-day moving average
.  And
on the right is SK Nix. Well, it was quite strong on its own
after the launch of individual stock leverage ETFs,
and the stock price was relatively strong while
receiving momentum from the ADR listing. However, since the
32-point gap is still somewhat wide,
looking solely at what Yeon-geun said from a technical analysis perspective, I
think Samsung Electronics might be in a more favorable position right now.
Yesterday, it seems that the stock price trend itself showed the former being
quite relatively stronger
.
And in the table on the left, foreign selling
continues to be quite strong.
As you mentioned earlier, selling
pressure of over 100 trillion won is emerging, and
around 149 trillion won.
And on the right is the KOSPI pension fund
purchase.  Even the KOS Pension Fund has been
continuously selling since around April
.  And
uh, I understand that the pension fund's exposure to Korean stocks is currently around
29%
.
Well, considering various conditions, it was suggested that the rate needs to be
lowered to 8%,
which means about 40 trillion won
needs to be sold.
But as you mentioned earlier,
despite that massive selling spree by foreigners, the index went up
following the fundamentals, didn't it?
And pension funds aren't selling
10 trillion won a day to the extent that it would significantly impact the market; they would likely
sell in the trillions of won at most. So, I do
n't think there is a possibility that the market will be shaken that much
.
Okay, Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix
are listed like this, but looking at past patterns,
Samsung Electronics has always reached its peak first, right?
Hmm, Samsung Electronics peaked in November 2017 and SK
Hynix in May 2018. In 2021,
Samsung Electronics peaked in January and SK
Hynix in April. So, if
Samsung Electronics keeps breaking new highs, you can just
assume SK Hynix is ​​okay for now. But if three months have passed and SK
Hynix is ​​breaking new highs while Samsung Electronics is stagnating and failing to do so, then you might think, "
Ah, should SK
Hynix take off now?"  yes.   Would
n't it be fine to think of it that way?
I had that thought based on past examples, and
Hynix's peak does tend to be quite
similar to Micron's.   hmm.
Micron has
often been the last to reach its peak,
so please keep that in mind. Also,
since very strong earnings announcements are scheduled for the end of July,
naturally, if we look at the results, it is
highly likely that both companies will hit new highs. However,
because the market is always smart, if the
phenomenon I just mentioned appears, you might want to
consider whether you should cut your holdings now.
Oh, and there was also selling by pension funds.
When it recently reached 9,300, the domestic weighting
probably exceeded 30% of the total assets, which are over 1,600 trillion won.  yes.
yes.  Since it exceeded 30%,
regarding strategic asset allocation, it was something like plus or
minus 5%, so up to 29% is
fine, but if it went over 30%, there is
no choice but to sell. That is why some selling
occurred in advance. It was the same in
2021; foreign
pension funds were all selling, but the market didn't
fall.   Back
then, zero interest rates were implemented, and
since the US market itself remained strong, it was fine as long as it did
n't fall despite sell pressure while constantly comparing the US market with the global market
.  When the market starts to turn down,
since many of the investors who have been absorbing the supply came in at the very end, they tend to react
most sensitively when the market takes a downturn
.   It's
broken.   At the same time,
since a hose has emerged that is suddenly gushing out of the market, we need to continue
monitoring the US market.
Next, there is one more reporter; there
was a data report by Researcher Kim Min-kyung regarding a market with a clear supplier advantage.  An official announcement regarding the award of a contract was also
released.  So, looking at the details first, it is said that the
target price has been raised to 3 million won
.  So it seems they
set the target price very high
.  The target share price was calculated by applying a
target multiple of 60 times the 2028 estimated EPS to the
table.   Actually, around this
time, I don't think I've seen many cases where the target price is calculated by
pulling performance data from 28 years ago to write a report
.   Based on
the research, it seems they have extended the figure to 2028 because they believe profit
growth will likely become quite evident by 2028
.
So, it is said that a 40% premium was applied compared to the EB's 28-year forecast
.  It seems like they are saying they will give it an even higher value than Ibidem
.
With the expansion of data center demand, the
supply shortage of MLCCs and Pitch BJs is becoming a reality, and it is
projected that steep earnings growth will continue until 2028.   It is said that the
expansion of AI-servicing production capacity by global MSCC manufacturers is accelerating the decline in general-purpose MLCC production
capacity
.  It is judged that the market for data center-type ultra-compact or
ultra-high-capacity MLC will
be concentrated among global top-tier companies
.  And it is said that Plitz BJ's
price negotiation power is also strengthening somewhat amidst a limited supply environment
.  It is reported that profitability is being calculated somewhat faster due to the
expansion of the sales proportion of network servers and price increases for all products
.  I mentioned that recently, as the demand for embedded flash BJs with
built-in silicon capacitors or passive components has
increased, the proportion of high-profit products is expanding,
and
premium valuations can be applied compared to IT component manufacturers
.
It is said that expansion is underway due to concerns regarding high-value MCCs.  Samsung Electro-Mechanics
disclosed a single supply contract for MSCs worth approximately 450 billion won today, and it is understood that this is a contract for
ultra-small or ultra-high capacity MSCs for AI data centers in 2027
.   The
fact that a 27-year supply volume has been contracted long-term at this point suggests that the
mid-to-long-term MSC supply and demand for OX4 is growing amidst the surge in demand for high-value MS in AI servers
.  The market price suggests that MCC is
establishing itself as a core component of AI servers
.  Uh, especially regarding the
server sector—specifically the ultra-compact and ultra-small sizes—
since Electric and Murata have completely dominated the market, I haven't heard of any other companies at all
.  Since technological capabilities are currently lacking,
these companies will expand their market share and
take over all these files. If this happens, a
product mix will emerge, and I think it is correct to assume that there is a
very high possibility that margins will increase
.  Next, I talked about the Plitz PJ
.  This
is the long-term outlook and prospects for the favorable market environment.  It is said that demand for AI data center
accelerators and ServerPi
remains strong.  It is said that as semiconductor
large-area fabrication leads to larger-area fabrication and
higher layering, capacities are
becoming more severe.
I heard that the fairness is very severe.  In
the case of Data Center PLJ, the
CEO there once made a comment about it even at a previously established school, and I suppose the
situation is the same for Netizens, Innotek, and Samsung Electro-Mechanics.
Despite large-scale expansions by global power plant manufacturers, the actual
increase in supply may be more limited than expected
.  So, it is understood that top-tier PCB manufacturers are
selectively receiving advance payments from their clients
.  It is said that due to the Titan supply environment,
entry prices are rising rapidly not only on servers but also on PC and the previous game, Fleet Page
.  So, I said that this
trend in profitability is likely to continue for a long period rather than being short-term
.  It seems a bit similar to memory
.  When HBM first
started to take over the mainstream memory market, it
began to significantly encroach on capacity.  But well, it
seems like MNCC and now Playch PJ are both the same.  Even
those Tier 2 and Tier 3 MSCC suppliers from China and Taiwan are
raising their prices right now
.  However, companies like Samsung Electro-Mechanics and
EBIN are shifting all their low-to-mid-range MCC
operations to the die server or automotive electronics sectors, and the
lower-tier companies are filling that gap
.  By the Naxxramas effect.  So, we
can [snort] that part,
and the same goes for the Plitz BJ. Since our highest-
performance Plitz BJ is
handled by Electric and Ibiden, the remaining
files are being
taken by companies like Daeduck Electronics and Korea Circuit below it.
Therefore, I think the benefits are
currently spreading to various industries
.  It seems like the cold weather is
continuing to rise.
When I estimated the profit of the MSCC business unit, I actually projected that next year's profit would be around 2 trillion won
.  But
now the estimate has
risen to almost 2.5 trillion won.  I think
the price of the MLCC steps was around 6 won, or about
6.6 won
.  It seems like it would need to
exceed 7 won to reach 2.5 trillion won, but that would require assuming a
40% price increase compared to the first quarter of this year
.  Well, then I guess that could happen
.  Because right now, that
5 won figure doesn't reflect the price increase at all
.  When you were in Japan.  But if they say they are
starting to raise prices now, they used to go
up by 40% in the past as well.
In that super compatible machine.  But the point is that it's even better than that super compatible machine
.  now.  Because while the
previous ultra-compatible devices were mobile PCs,
now they are in the data centers, battlefields, and AI
sectors. When demand for such mobile PCs was
high, it went up by 40%, but
now it is likely even higher than that.  Then, I get the feeling that
the researchers are making estimates based on the assumption that it will rise by more than 40%
.  Looking at next year's company-wide performance,
sales are projected to reach 16 trillion won.
It seems that the operating profit is projected to be around 3.4 trillion won.   On
the right, I brought data on the future stratosphere
.  The outlook is that while the cycle structure remains the same, the
nature of demand appears to be undergoing a structural change in the short term
.   I
wrote a comment below regarding the nature of the demand.  It
seems like they are talking about 2017, a
time when there was a short-term surge driven by smartphones. They
mentioned that since the current trend is driven by AI and servers, there is a high possibility of a gradual and continuous rise.
So, looking at the current situation, it is
viewed somewhat as a cycle similar to the 2017 cycle, and it
seems that an additional upward ASP cycle is also considered sustainable.
So, the 2017 case is on the left
.
Yagao started raising prices in September 2017,
raised them again in November 2017, and
raised them a bit at the end of 2017 as well, and it is the
same now.  Yagao and other
mid-to-low-priced MCC companies
started raising their prices first.
Next, a trend is expected to emerge where the value of electricity and EB
rises to high levels, and it
seems likely that this will continue this year and next year.  So, in the end, what I want to say is that is the point
.  In the past,
smartphone and PC demand moved solely according to the economic cycle, but
since this is a B2B cycle largely unrelated to the economic cycle, it
seems that the cycle itself is viewed as potentially being prolonged.
On the next page, there is a guide to
tightening strength based on a 5-stage qualitative evaluation by category; the first
part discusses Fritch PJ, HPM, and memory substrates
.  I think it would be good to just look at the parts here that are labeled as bottleneck, bottleneck,
bottleneck
.  As expected, the biggest bottleneck is
painted in orange HPM.  Next, there are
two orange lines each for FC BJ and MLCC, and
globally, Samsung Electro-Mechanics is the only company that produces both FC BJ and MLCC.
So, I think there is definitely an advantage in that aspect
.  Actually, if you
look at the table on the right, I have
shown you a similar car before regarding memory. This
is a comparison of the base cost of Vera Rubin compared to the GB 300, and it is a
table showing how much the base cost for each part has increased compared to the previous version. Well, for
memory, it is more than five times.
Next, it is currently projected that PCBs will increase fourfold, MSCs
fourfold, and FlashPrices one or twofold
.
[Clears throat]
So, I
think this red one has the strongest stock price based on the standard of a significant increase in cost-benefit ratio.
Memory is the strongest first, followed
by PCB, MLCC, and flip-flops; these companies definitely have
good stock prices.  Companies like Syntech, Daeduck, and Samsung
Electro-Mechanics are relatively
stronger compared to other materials, parts, and equipment manufacturers, so it
seems we can see that they face the strongest shortages in that area.
The ticket is nice.  Looking at it,
based on the five-stage qualitative evaluation of Hataek and Goryeobyul, the tining intensity was projected, showing whether years
2026, 2027, and 2028 are
bottlenecks or if the bottleneck is intensifying. There is also something
related to Veraru on the right,
but yesterday, WomanShinPark ShinmunIldagai asked, "
Do you know roughly how large the overall MLCC market is?"
Ah, if
we say something is good, we need to
know the market size, you know.
So, well,
next year or the year after, the item can be
multiplied up to a certain amount.  Well, they do it like this,
yes.
So, regarding the market size,
even just looking at semiconductors, the
memory market used to be about 200 trillion won, but
now it has dropped to almost 100 trillion won, and while
prices have jumped significantly, let's leave it at that
. As for MNCC, yes, I will explain it to you while reading the body's heart rate yesterday.  As AI
establishes itself as a key driving force for the growth of the MLCC market, the
market size is also expected to expand rapidly.
According to market research firm Business Research Insights, the global MLCC
market size is projected to reach
$4.27 billion (
approximately 6 trillion won) this year,
and $
5.56 billion (approximately
8 trillion won) by 2030.  hmm.
But if you look at Samsung Electro-Mechanics'
component sales alone over 26 years, it's 6 trillion won.
So, doesn't
that Flickby PCB go into the components
?  Or it went into the package side, it
went into the package side, and just
MLCC. Just MLCC right now, yes, yes, they say it
goes in there. Just the
component CC, uh,
component. Looking at this, I thought, "Is
n't the MLCC market size only this small
?"   I'll have to
check this while reading yesterday.   It will take until
2035 to
grow to $8.09 billion.  Please ask a few questions
.   yes
.
So, saying the items were too small,
companies also started raising prices.  It is reported that the price of
Murata’s
40 trillion microfarad products, which are high-capacity, high-value products and ranked first in the world, has
increased from 0.2 yuan to 0.65 yuan per unit since May.   The difference in
the engine is really bad.
Some sources say that
Modern Intelligence is $31.87 billion
.   I also have
32 billion dollars. Yes.
And if you calculate it as Mahwa, it's roughly from
20 trillion to 49 trillion. Yes, that's right.   From about
20 to 49 trillion, yes, that is correct
.
Because electricity accounts for
about 20 to 30% of the global market, but the
revenue is 6 trillion.  And well, regarding the second one, I
understand that Murata is a bit bigger than that. Even if you combine just the two, it would
be around 14 trillion or 16 trillion.
Since the previous year's share is 20%, you just have to multiply the previous year's revenue by
5,
right?  Then, 6 trillion, 5, 6,
30, 30 trillion.   Right
?  So, if it is similar, that is fine, but
generally there is a difference. Between 30 trillion and 50 trillion,
30 trillion... uh, that amount is
yes, that is correct.
Sometimes when I read the news...
yes.  Ah,
there are times when I wonder if the numbers are correct.
yes.
Yesterday, I saw that the Terminator movie came out in
1984, so I thought, "Ah, that must be
wrong, it should be 1994," but it turned out that
1984 was correct.  [Laughs]
Hmm.
Anyway, that is the size of the MLCC market
.
yes.  And it is somewhat oligopolistic.
In the past, this electric market was around Tier 1.5.
Did Murata and the Taiwanese company Yageo hold the number one market share?   So,
Murata,
then Yageo, and then
Korea's Samsung Electro-Mechanics are
slightly at the top of the hierarchy. Are
there any Chinese companies, like MSC, that are catching up to the general-purpose market right now?   yes
.  It's enough below.
Ah, it's at the bottom.
It's in the top 10, but it's completely at the bottom right
now. I'm not sure about 1st place, everyone is 2nd or
3rd. Even the medicine has
gone down even further.   When
we look at stocks, we always consider whether the
industry's pie is continuously growing amidst competition within the industry, right?
I understand that while the industry's growth potential is important, we must also always keep an eye on the competitive landscape.
So, as the title suggests, it is still a
supplier-dominated market.
It is a seller's market.
This year's performance growth is simply due to a recovery in capacity utilization, whereas
next year's growth will be driven by price increases.
So, the valuation is indeed very high
.   The point is that it makes
sense if you look at the benefits
.  This year's operating profit
is 1.7 trillion won, and next year it will be 3.4 trillion won.
91% growth again this year.  98%
growth next year.   Since it is a
forecast, for
example, if it is 100 times now, you can
see talk that it will drop to 50 times next year
.  That is why it
feels like people buy it even at a high price.   There is
probably nothing special to expect from numbers 2 and 3
.  hmm.
The price has already risen this much,
so there is no room for further upward adjustment
.
The key is the captured one.   I think I
caught it.   It's a
current situation, but next year we have to determine the annual supply
contract.  So, the price can be
determined.
So, if we enter the fourth round next year,
there is a possibility if we just look at next year's performance.
So the key point is the
fourth quarter rather than the second and third quarters.   hmm.  hmm.   I
look forward to that even more.
The numbers for the second and third quarters
won't come out properly yet, but they are correct starting from the fourth quarter
.   uh
.  uh.
I see, that's good.
And Samsung Electro-Mechanics
rises explosively when it goes up, but if you
get the wrong pick at the peak, it
is a stock that will take five years to recover.
So, we need to keep studying like this
.  hmm.
All right.  Thank you.  So, the market has
started.
How is it going?
Yes, the market started up 1.36%
.  It is currently falling slightly to plus 0.89%
.
It's all backed up.
Night futures rose 1.58 yesterday,
starting around the level of the peak, and are currently
facing slight selling pressure.   yes
.
Is the investment volume coming out?   yes
.  wait a minute.  I'll take a look.   It looks like it will
come out with foreign investors, government agencies, and institutions selling.   yes
.  Foreign investors are currently
selling about 350 billion won in the market
.  And there is currently about 100 billion won in selling pressure on the KOSDAQ as well
.  Foreign investors are
selling quite heavily.
The institution is currently buying about 600 million in the market
.  About 650 billion
.
Ah, I'm buying, and oh, individual investors are selling too
.   yes
.
So, what should be done about KOSDAQ?
Yes, the KOSDAQ market started up 0.86%
.  Uh, currently it is
at 0.17%
.  yes.
Starting at 0.8 and going to 0.39, the KOSDAQ today... those
EcoPro brothers,
yes.  hmm.  You know Yujeong was over there.
I saw that there was an oil well that accounted for about 10%, so it looks like it will be
delayed a bit.   yes
.  It's dropping by about 4% today.
I think it was delayed by more than 10% compared to yesterday's time.
Still, I am recovering little by little as I start today
.   Things
like secondary batteries weren't very good in the market yesterday, either
.  Did they reflect this a little in advance
?  hmm.  I did have that
thought, too.
Now, yesterday I
had an investment briefing for the Ministry of Finance, so I only covered gold and
left.
How did you handle the outlook for the new model yesterday
?
Glass part.
Now, both were set to rise.   Uh oh
.   I suppose you
predicted a rise for Asdaq, SNPB, and Philban.
yes.  That is correct.
What happens today?   I will make
both rise again today.
Both rising again today.
Our pro is having a hard time matching both the SP 500 and Nastar
.
What about the general one?   I will
rise.
The US is rising across the board.
yes.
Then,
what did they say about the domestic situation yesterday?
I, Costa, spoke with a bearish candle.   Bearish
candle.  It was a bearish candle yesterday.   I
did.
Looking at the win rate, and seeing the win rate Yeol is getting, it's
steadily rising,
hmm.
Manager Oh went straight up, too.
ah.  yes.
So, what's going on today?
Uh, Costa still
came out with a bearish candle.
The KOSDAQ is still showing a bearish candle.
What happens to the KOSPI?   I need to take a look at the
speed chart.   Regarding the
chart analysis I couldn't do yesterday, today
seems like a very tricky day. While
semiconductors in the U.S. rose significantly,
Micron performed a bit sluggishly.
These days, to accurately predict the KOSPI, you absolutely have to look at
Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix, since they account for
over 50% of the market.
Yes, that is correct.   We
need to analyze these too.
But it seems like investors are
starting to have some doubts now, so there is suspicion regarding semiconductors, specifically
memory semiconductors
.   yes
.   hmm.
Well, as I mentioned yesterday, when the market plunged
on Friday,
and then on Monday—normally, if the trend follows the same
pattern, memory should have been the strongest when a rebound occurs—but
memory dropped by 4%.   uh
.
The market turned positive, but
looking at that, I feel it has
changed significantly from the previous trend. You know, that gut feeling I get—it
feels like the momentum has weakened a bit.
Since everything rebounded slightly yesterday, I expect a correction today, so I will give it a try
.  Oh, right. I'm
looking at the Samsung Electronics chart right now, and
uh, it's not a very strong chart.   yes
.   Right
?   yes
.
And Hynix
hit a high of 2,987,000 won on June 25th and is
currently hovering around 2,653,000 won, so I
wonder how the US market is
doing?
There is a feeling that they will wait and see how things unfold in early July, and with the US 10-year Treasury yield surpassing
4.4% again yesterday, it
seems this will have some influence on sentiment.  Employment figures are good, and as I
mentioned earlier, the
CPI will be released before July 10th. It does
n't look like the CPI will drop. As for
the war, I'm not really interested in it anymore, but
looking at the end of the war, it
doesn't seem like it will happen, so it looks like they will keep
dragging it on.  From
President Trump's perspective, with interest rates
falling due to the land-based fire, he is trying to force a
60-day ceasefire to get the oil
tankers currently trapped in Hormuz to come over quickly. However, the
Revolutionary Guard is no pushover; they are
formidable.
It seems the noise surrounding them will continue to surface.  It's just that people are getting used to it now
compared to when this war first broke out
.  The fact that they are not seeing a significant threat
.  Those aspects
are positive, but since the
market isn't weak yet, we need to
keep watching to see where the downsides will come from, and I
understand what will come up when the semiconductor market takes a break.  I will.
Okay, that’s all for
today’s program
.  Oh, right, regarding Day 5,
Rulebreak, you got all the bearish candles right on Day 5, didn't you?
I saw what you posted in the last comment yesterday.
Rulebreaker, since you called to pick up the
book and got everything right on the first try, I will
give you another ticket to the Monthly Tournament tomorrow evening.   You may
come and pick up the book
.  yes.  So, today, July
1st,
ah, going back and forth matching the index.
Okay, I will now announce the
June index matching
results.
I see that Henim
predicted 8,555, and ah, the closing price for June was
8,476, so it
ended exactly that way, almost like a piece of cake.
yes.
You mentioned 8.55, and it is 1st place.   Mr. Chae Buja
predicted 2nd place at 8,500, and the
5th round was 23.5. Wait a minute, then
isn't Mr. Choi Buja in 1st place?   It
ended at 8,476.48, so
Manager Choi, who predicted 8,500, is in first place, right?  2nd place is
8,55, and
Ottugi is 8,700.
8,700 was 200, right?   That's right
.  Right?
This optimistic outlook was dominant.
What is it?  Since May saw
such a sharp rise in April and May,
out of 47 total participants, number
36 predicted that it would be higher than 8,476.
Three people [cleared their throats] were controlled regarding the accuracy of the minority opinion and the actual closing price, and
there was one person who said the lowest value was 6,950, and there were
also those who predicted 11,800.
yes.  Congratulations to Mr. Choi Buja, Mr. Hae, and Mr. Ottugi
.  I would like to give you the recently published book "Real
Rich, Fake Rich" by Accountant Sa Kyung-in as a
gift.
Now, yes, I would like you to write down the forecast for July as well
.
Now, the figures for the first half of July are steadily rising.
Looking at the forecast, there are many forecasts for 9,500, 11,500,
1600, 9,000, 9,450, 8,
9,800, and
8, as well as many forecasts for the mid-8 and 90 million
.  Recently, good books have been continuously being
delivered to me.  yes.
Grandfather's second book is also coming out.   hmm.
So, yes, I would appreciate it if you could actively participate
.   yes
.  That concludes today's Chasley Morning Briefing for July
1st.   I
hope you have a healthy and happy day today.
Thank you.
do.